Welcome back to quantum computing in practice. This episode is going to focus on the first and often the most
challenging step in defining a quantum program. Mapping a general problem to a circuit that can run on a quantum
computer. This step describes how a user starting with a given computational
problem can translate it so a quantum computer can understand.
In previous lessons of this series, lessons two and three, we discussed that the mapping stage is the first step out
of four in the Qiskit patterns framework. From these lessons, you may remember that our goal was to translate
or rewrite a computational problem into a cost function or an expectation value
that we can evaluate using a quantum computer.
In lesson three, we discussed one concrete example with max cut, a problem
that is computationally hard and that is common place in combinatorial optimization.
In that example, we went through several steps to transform the initial graph into a quantum native problem. We
transformed the problem of finding the maximum number of cuts in the graph into a cost function. then rewrote that cost
function as a Hamiltonian and prepared a trial quantum state whose ground state
corresponds to the max cut. Finally, we constructed a quantum circuit representing the trial quantum state of
interest and then added the specific gates to allow the state to evolve over time. This sequence of steps is what we
call mapping. And at a high level, the procedure is general to many other applications such as quantum chemistry
and quantum simulation. Now, there's no shying away from the fact that mapping can be difficult. There isn't a
one-sizefits-all strategy for every single problem, so it can be intimidating. Today, I will highlight
some representative examples of different problems and describe how they were mapped in each case. I will quickly
recap what we learned about graph problems like those used in Max Cut and spend the rest of the lecture focusing
on how to map problems that appear in nature such as molecular structure problems in biology, electronic
structure problems in chemistry and simulation of quantum field theories in high energy physics.
But before we spend most of our time in this episode looking at example problems from the literature, I want to give you
a high-level look at the main things that we want to accomplish and consider when we're mapping a problem. There are
a few things to consider for any type of computational problem that will need to be translated into a quantum circuit.
First, you might need to simplify the problem to make it feasible. This is something commonplace to most scientific
disciplines. This is not unique to quantum computing. If you have ever heard of the expression assume a
spherical cow, it is alluding to the fact that it is often hard to describe a system exactly as it appears. But
instead, we can make reasonable simplifications that still can lead to helpful solutions.
Some examples of how we might do this in quantum computing are to limit the size or the circuit depth by choosing a
hardware efficient onzoths or truncating complex time evolutions or neglecting
Hamiltonian terms that contribute little to the final energy of a quantum state.
The next point I want to make is that you are going to have to think about writing the problem in such a way that a quantum computer can make sense of it.
Often that involves asking these three questions. One, what will our cubits
represent in this model? Two, is our problem continuous? Since quantum computers are digital, you will need to
find a way to discretise the problem. And three, lastly, does the topology of the problem align with the topology of
the hardware? If yes, that's great. But if not, we might need to implement some tricks to make it work. So let's address
this first question. What I think is at the heart of all the difficulties with understanding mapping especially as a
new concept. What can a cubit represent?
Cubits can be used to represent many things. The first and simplest in my opinion is a node on a graph. Graphs are
used to show connectivity and many different types of mathematical problems. And the nodes are a fundamental element representing a point
or entity within a network. Depending on what the whole network represents, that could be a city, a person or a
ferromagnet in a lattice. Cubits can also be used to represent bzons and firmians. Although I will caution here
that one single cubit does not exactly equal one bon or one firmian. It's a bit
trickier than that and I will go into it shortly, but in general, a chain of spins that follow some statistics is
something that can be easily translated to a cubit architecture.
Now, we're getting into examples that are a bit more complicated. For these models, it doesn't make sense anymore to
speak in terms of a single cubit.
Instead, we need groups of them to make up something physical. For example, a
group of cubits here represented on a heavy hexagonal topology can be used to represent geometrical locations of amino
acids or polymer chains. Another example is the simulation of hadron scattering
in high energy physics models which can be done by simulating the time evolution of a hydronic wave packet. In this case,
a register of cubits can be used to encode different states of a quantum field. The vacuum state of that field or
a wave packet that propagates on top of this vacuum.
Now I also want to note that mapping the problem to a quantum computer has distinct steps which are one mapping the
states onto cubits and circuits and two mapping the cost function or expectation
of the quantum observables and operators. We will see how these are handled in specific examples. But at
this point we have spoken abstractly enough about the challenge before us.
Let's look into these examples now in detail.
Let's begin with our first example. In my opinion, one of the easiest mapping problems is the one that we have already
covered in some depth, the max cut example. In that problem, the mapping was pretty easy for us because one cubit